[Music]
Okay. So, let's first talk about again.
So, here's here's the thing.
Um,
like we know that I'm ground vectoring,
right? Does that make sense? And um are
you all right? Okay. All right.
We know the discourse is like let the
energy in and then you're trying to
vector it down. Okay. And yesterday we
were trying this drill
and it started to expose this rotational
integrity and then this top of the quad
integrity. Okay,
but here's the thing.
If my when I do the hand drills, it
wasn't so exposable, right? Wasn't so
sensible.
But if my hand is staying still like
she's pushing, do you see? And I'm not
doing this. She's pushing and I'm not
doing that. Do you get that?
If my hand stays still, then what else
stays still is my shoulder. Do you get
that? Like the shoulder has to move to
do those other things.
So somewhere
in there
is
a very
hard thing to understand because we are
somehow in the placing of my hand there
I'm able to stabilize the shoulder. Do
you see that? But without my hand there
then I can't stabilize the shoulder. So
there's a lot of just
almost like faith like you're not
believing it. Do do you know what I
mean? Like maybe if you picture your
hand there and she's pushing and you
could get more the same idea. Do do you
understand? Okay. So we'll try that. Um,
but some of you already experience the
difference between
the force coming in and going down and
me just pushing back on it. Okay.
What happens when you stand
and particularly when you're not ground
vectoring on the back foot, when your
line of gravity is between your two
feet, you have a bracing angle. Do do
you get that? But when we're seated, we
we can't we don't have a bracing angle.
Okay? It's a it's a very good reason why
you do suadiwaza because you will not
use bracing angles. Okay? It's harder to
use bracing angles. Um
so if I'm here and she's she's pushing
on me and I try to brace on that that
whatever that point is. You see, I'm
trying to brace on that point. If she
can outy yong me, then you you get
picked up like you guys are
experiencing. Do you see? And um
the reaction is to flex more, right? To
try to hold the place more. But as you
as you try to hold your legs more, it
just makes you more lever and you you
you get lighter to her. Okay? Does that
make sense? Okay. So,
um, we're going to do the two drills,
the previous one and then the one where
we're going to fake your your arm. Okay?
I don't I don't know if you've seen
those experiments. Have you seen these
experiments where they have a person
um uh with a curtain right down the
middle and they have them put their arm
on here and then they have a fake arm.
They know it's a fake arm. Do you see
that? But as they're touching the fake
arm with the feather, they're touching
the real arm with the feather. And they
just keep doing these various
experiments to where they hit the fake
arm with a hammer and they're like, "Ah,
like they get a pain response." Okay. Um
to me what this is telling me is there
is this for lack of a better word a
subconscious aspect to all this which is
why you have to use metaphysical
discourses because we can't tap into it
through scientific discourse because
that's not our subconscious. Okay. So
we'll play with that and see if it gets
us anywhere. All right. Um, so the first
drill that we did is a kind of gradual
pressure because we know on you guys if
she if she just comes in and pushes me
real hard, you're I'm I'm going to do
that other thing. Okay. So, just a
gradual pressure. She just first with
touch and then like zen and you'll
you'll you'll feel it if you can. Okay.
You'll feel me drop
and then she'll increase the pressure
and with each pressure I am particularly
know that my hands my arms never had
anything to do with it. So release that
tension
and then my legs
they don't have anything to do with it.
So I release that tension
and she's gradually
increasing the pressure.
Okay,
she's pushing pretty good there at the
end, right? Okay. And then the next
drill
is
you'll you'll have your hands like
you're trying to keep extension. Okay,
got it? You're gonna have to use your
imagination like someone's pushing on
your hands and she'll do the same
gradual pressure
and you keep when you feel this pressure
I want you to in your mind extend your
arms your arms out. Do you get it? So
don't keep your arms long. And she keeps
going.
When you feel like, oh, that's where I
want to flex. Instead, I want you to
reach out.
Okay. For me, I can't release as much
because
I'm consciously trying to to reach out.
Do you know what I mean? I could feel
I'm not as dropping. Okay. But let's see
what happens with you guys. Okay. All
right. Let's try it. And we know we know
what's happening when I get pushed over.
I'm flexing. I made a lever out of my
body. Okay. Try it. Okay. And uh
comments or observations?
Yes.
I noticed this more on the second than
the first, but I think it was there
second time through. Uh I think it was
there both that there was a pressure at
which this And that part of the back
especially became flex and I couldn't
release out of that and then immediately
starting.
Okay.
All right. Uh let's
let's try this. Okay.
Um
I'm trying to try to see how how we can
do this. Okay. and you come around me.
I've done this before. Okay.
Uh you're going to you're going to put
your hands from behind me on my
midsection. Don't don't squeeze me
though. Okay. Just kind of light. Okay.
And uh
because you do need that structural
integrity in in the in this midsection
because it's the top of the qua. Do do
you understand? Okay. What you should
feel is when you'll feel like uh I'm
going to do it externally. You'll feel
something like that. Okay. And when she
feels that, you're going to feel this.
Okay.
All right. So, we're doing drill one
again. She starts to to press.
Did you feel it drop? Yes. And then, did
you feel it get big? Yes. Okay. Do you
see it? So now I have this huge thing in
the middle
that you can keep pushing
it. It it cannot it cannot do this. I I
have to let it go. So I'll do that and
you'll you'll feel it get small again.
Okay. So you're going to you you're
going to feel for the drop. When she
feels that drop, you'll feel you'll feel
that. Okay. There's the drop.
And then I'm going to un unhinge that
top claw and you'll feel that it got
smaller. Okay. So
what this that's your lower tand she
goes there goes that it's right it's
right when she pushes she's forming it
in a way. And now I have this she can
keep pushing. I have this thing that you
just you're not going to be able to ever
bend backwards. Do you see? And the
interesting part, you can see that the
more she's pushing, the bigger it's
getting. Okay. And now I'm going to
release that that back line, the Ming
men line. So I dropped more and it got
bigger. Do you see? And then there's
there's just no way that it because it
doesn't have a hinge now. And now I can
I can move wherever. Okay.
So I do want that.
I understand that there's that top
hinge,
but we don't want to flex.
We want the pressure to build and the
pressure will build by releasing the
tension. Okay, that that is yes, there's
an architectural
fulfillment that has to happen. It just
doesn't happen by the flexing which
shrinks the tanden. Okay. Um
there's things I can do with this. So I
kind of hinted at it that I can I can
move now wherever. Okay. So when I go
forward
physically what do you know happens to
the force value at contact it should
increase because the imposing energy
right but that energy is just going down
now do you see into that tanden and so I
don't feel the the increase but she
feels like that is getting
powerful. She feels the force. Do do you
get what I'm saying? Okay. So, and uh
that's the difference between external
internal.
So, for example, what you'll see in a
lot of Iikido people, a lot like even O
Sensei, he he he would do it all from
here, but I have a bum knee. When you do
it from from cross-legged,
you can lean more forward. Do do you get
what I'm saying? Kind of like how Ellie
does it. She she can lean very forward.
In sea you can't you can't lean as as
far forward. So you see uh so that I
like the sea better regardless
but some people will do it in sea and
you'll see that they'll come they anchor
here. Do you see this is a physical
um reinforcing of my position. Okay. So
when she pushes I I
push up on her. Do you see? She pushes
and I keep pushing up on her. She pushes
and I keep pushing up on her, but I
cannot move from here. I cannot get up.
I push towards her and it's just
increasing the yong value, but I can't
go past past it. Do do you understand?
So it's the same thing when you brace in
your tachiwaza
you're getting pinned when when you do
that and you cannot move and that
doesn't make sense combatively. Okay. So
this will be the next discovery
learning. They're going to push. I just
have my hands underneath her elbows and
as she's driving you just keep lifting
up on on their elbows. Okay. It's not
that you're you're taking away. You'll
see that oh yeah that's pushing me down
and keeping me in place. Okay. But
you'll also see as as you go forward,
you can't really go forward on her.
Okay. All right. So, let's try that
discovery learning. This is an external
uh gaining of positional integrity. Try.
Okay. Um what do you think?
There's no going forward. You're like
stuck. We're in a stalemate. You see?
And so this is like uh why I say there's
really no non-contestation externally.
Do you know what I mean? Like you you
have you have to um you have to
deconstruct the dichotomy
um so that you're not pushing back on
them. They're pushing on you, but you're
not pushing on them. Okay. Now, what
modern Iikido has done is go, "Well,
I'll just get out of the way." Do you
know what I mean? And so then they're
like, "I'm not pushing on you. I'm
getting out of the way. But you, it
doesn't work. It doesn't function
marshally. Um, it's too intellectual a
process that can't function at speed of
life. Which is why even in Kihon Waza,
they push back on the the UK. Do do you
know what I mean? Okay. All right. Well,
I'll show you another thing on um why
why this doesn't work. Okay. What what
the difference is.
So she is going to she's here. I let
that that thing form, right? And then
you can see that I can move anywhere.
Well, I can also move
this way. She's pushing. You see? And I
can move back.
When you do the other one and you're
here like this and you go back and
you're like, you're not coming back.
Okay? Do you get that? So you can't even
get your angles of deviation
uh because you're stuck. And so anytime
you do your any yield which is in the
art, you can't capitalize upon it. It's
just creating yin space that they f they
fulfill with their yong energy. Okay. So
we'll try I don't this again. She's
she's going to go you you guys probably
can't come back
now anyways. Do you get it?
But you can try this one. Your hair,
she's you're you're stuck in place. I
want you to disconnect it and you'll
see. Ah, everything fell apart. Okay.
You could probably try that one. Um,
since we're since we're here too, as
she's as she's driving and it forms and
I can go here.
Do do you get it? And I can come back.
I can go here as I go back too. Do you
see?
So, and again, none none of that's
possible. I don't I don't get to play
with all the contact points whether I'm
adhering or whether I'm projecting. I
just got this thing here that I can't do
anything with. Okay. So, your discovery
learning exercise is get get here. Okay.
Push push push push your chair. Okay.
She can't push me. And now I want you to
try to do that. And you're like, "Oh,
yeah.
Okay. And you know that's basically EQL.
You see every time we do the front
inward kazushi, you're doing that. So
all your front inward kazushi
techniques, they don't actually
function. Okay. All right. Let's try
that discovery learning. Okay. All
right. So you you guys can see this just
doesn't work. And there's more things
you can do.
Um because uh control and projection,
right? Or adhesion and projection. Um,
not only can you play with diff
different arms, but between those two
forces, you have multiple degrees. So,
you can um you can do an adhesion to
such a degree that it's actually
slippery slippery on them. And the other
one there's no just friction is just
freaking stuck on there. Okay? So, you
can't even do that. You can't play with
the variations in the force values.
Okay? All right. So, here's what we got
to do.
We got to let go of all that external
stuff. It's not what we do. It's not
what we want. Okay?
And so
you're you're going to task yourself
with that releasing. Okay? Careful of
the flexion.
You're going to you're going to release
and let the pressure build up. Okay?
It's not uncommon that these internals
that people uh give themselves
hemorrhoids because they're they're
pushing to and it's not a pushing. I
didn't I didn't push that I release and
the pressure happens to me. Okay. Um so
don't don't do that because you'll hurt
yourself in the long run. Okay. All
right. So, as you feel the pressure,
you're going to let your I want you to
let tissues drop like you felt me drop.
Do you see that? Okay. But you can't
drop like this. Do you understand?
Inside the frame you have right now,
you're going to let tissues drop. So,
we're just here and you let tissues
drop.
Now, can you feel it dropping and coming
up and dropping and it's not your
breath? It's not breath. It's just it's
uh it's a release and then the habitual
tension that we carry around all day
unconsciously. I release it and it came
back. Okay?
But I'm telling you, the dropping
is closer to getting what we want and
it's the way to get what we want. Even
if it doesn't last. Do do you
understand? So I'm I don't know from 1
to 10, what would you say I'm pushing on
you right now? Okay. One or two. Okay. I
agree. All right. And that's enough
pressure for her to do this. Let it let
it go down.
And if when she feels it come back up,
she releases it again. Do do you
understand? Everyone understand? And
that that's the drill because that
releasing is all I'm doing. It's just
it's not coming back up. Okay. All
right. So, let's try that. Please
push around a one or two. Okay.